you guys are at it again here you are i
hope the two of you were inside of your
voiceover booth together doing the the
scenes for this film what are you
laughing at that yeah where did you're
what you got mr heart yeah tell us
what
but the chemistry between the two of
y'all is incredible i mean i feel like
it would have been a missed opportunity
if you weren't were you in the vo booth
together not a lot no no no no
unfortunately we weren't yeah but we
know each other we know each other's
timing and rhythm yeah so i made it easy
and then he would call me or send me
text messages or voice notes and like
hey dude i did it like this check this
out i do the same thing so it really
melded nicely but then we did get the
booth once yeah to make sure that there
were certain scenes that we had to be
opposite each other to find each other's
rhythm and groove yeah uh even more well
this just works it totally works and it
really works in this animated setting
deploy canine shield what is a k-9
[Applause]
[Applause]
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful so what is it about
these animated projects now you're just
like in the groove with that and is it
for the kids at this point what is it
yeah it definitely has a lot to do with
the kids i think um you had so many well
it's like you know well wait no
not dick cannon though
[Laughter]
we we're at a point now where we get to
kind of uh pick our poison right and
when you can make the choices um and
they're vetted out planned out um it's
it's a lot of fun and i think in this
space um you know he and his team had
this idea they took time and developing
the idea to make sure it was done right
it really cracked the code on the idea
that it's kind of simple but has been
ignored for quite some time i know i
can't believe it hasn't been done yet
because it's just a genius idea using
these superheroes that we all know and
love
putting your voices to them and then you
know they're from pets perspective yeah
it's like the two greatest things
superheroes and pets yeah so so we've
got you guys in these superhero modes
and plus we've got you coming out as
black adam we've got john krasinski
who's voicing uh man of steel in this
film he was also in another recent
superhero film so kev when are you going
to take on a superhero you're a real man
oh you know i really thought about it
but then i was like
man yeah like those roles are
stupid
um someone said why
why
he's upset i'd do it because i offered
him honky pete we wrote the script
i asked you several times sent it and
sent it to him and asked and asked and
asked and continuously ignored me
act as if you don't want me in the movie
you went and shot black adam
secretly told me that you weren't
working and i found out through social
media that you were done production
teaching literally i didn't i forgot
that we had that conversation i slipped
out a post a black out of said black
adam i heard his feelings then i tried
to send him honky pete and he's like i
don't want him i don't want him he's
yeah he's hurt no he's hurt okay take
the pete and get out of here he's gotta
lick his wounds he doesn't wait you look
bad until white adam comes up oh white
adam's what you got up your sleeve it's
a white adam come on oh really yeah yeah
after all we've been through now you're
gonna make white adam a man who sits on
the throne and has a rage
because of his past o
[Laughter]
since we're on the topic of black adam
can you give us a tease of how this is
going to be a different comic movie than
we've ever seen before um i think that
we are ushering in a new era of um
of anti-hero and what i love about black
adam is that uh he is a there's nothing
to reference before him so no one has uh
stood up this character before
the world it's it's a great opportunity
for us to introduce black adam to the
world but also um there's something
there's something really cool about when
you
when your origin is you have started off
as a slave and your family was enslaved
to and something happens to your family
and that is your driving
motivating factor and then you're
blessed by the gods with these powers
that rival that of superman um but yet
as he was saying there is really great
rage
from this man so i can't wait
my powers
are not a gift
but a curse
it's born out of rage
he thought it was good the trailer was
good yeah i wish i could trash it but i
can't tell it was really really good
because i wish i could say something bad
about it but i can't he can't it was
you know we love an e.t milestone we
love a movie milestone over at et and 20
years ago paper soldiers your first film
came out yes wow what do you think i
mean
when you made that turn what do you
think of when you think about that film
um you know that was a great opportunity
i got lucky i got to do a project early
on that didn't have like theatrical
success but it had street success so it
was heavily bootlegged and because of
that tape
that allowed me to get a manager agent
and
that really amplified my stand-up comedy
career so that movie did a lot without
doing a lot what was called paper solo
paper soldiers
a very funny movie
very funny movie wow how can i see it uh
well you have a dvd player
you can see it other than that you can't
see it no way no is it online well it's
gotta be somewhere i don't know if you
can
i don't know where you can actually find
oh my gosh
what was your role what did you play um
it was a movie loosely based off of a
true story these guys were burglars they
were crew of friends that was robbing
people's houses uh dame dash jay-z
introduced his movie early on myself
being siegel starred in it uh
and uh you know it was just a platform
for me to do what i do well yeah but
what what did you do in the movie i
don't understand well
he was amazing in the movies
really okay what'd you do 20 years ago
no but what did you do
what are you talking about when i hear
dave dash and jay-z and season's like
what
did you do
i can't you just dropped all kinds of
names well you know what it was anybody
yeah well how about we go back to 50
years ago when you did your first
project
you were a robber in the movie
you know what i would love to see
something like this play out at a major
award show i would love to see y'all
host something like the oscars the emmys
i'll try he turned me down you were
approached to host the emmys but you had
to turn it over so what happened why did
it work out
no i was and then i said no thank you
right but then also because it wouldn't
have fit within my schedule
but then the oscars came along knowing
anything and then it was supposed to be
kevin and i together for the oscars yeah
oh my god what happened wait is this
truth or is this
that one up
[Laughter]
kevin hart hosting the oscars biggest
oscars of all time i mean
wow the funniest oscars of all time so
why didn't rachel was there why didn't
it work out with the emmys dj
[Laughter]
tj we're gonna host the oscars i mean
whatever
on a serious note why didn't it work out
with the emmys this time around i was
just scheduled i mean i'm really truly
honored yeah you know they would come to
me and ask but it was just a scheduling
thing that's all that's really what it
comes down to fair enough and i know all
those guys over there i mean truly
honored awesome we heard you first no
no
as i was honored for the oscars and
ready to go